a movie finally exists where Batman
fights Superman on screen tell me how
not to get excited about that seriously
Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice and
this is a spoiler free review no
spoilers in this videos as you sit back
relax enjoy so Batman vs Superman dawn
of Justice is really the introduction to
the DC Cinematic Universe you could
argue that Menace steel is but this is
the one where you a Batman Superman
Wonder Woman they're all on screen
together and you get the feeling this is
now a bigger universe in the beginning
of this movie shows Bruce Wayne was
there in Metropolis when the whole
Throwdown between Zod and Superman went
down and destruction destruction
buildings got to say that city took hit
and that Bruce Wayne's a bit hell-bent
on waging war with this alien who could
destroy the entire world if you really
wanted to then you have Jesse Eisenberg
as Lex Luthor being a little twerp in
the movie and you know he has his own
agenda then you have Wonder Woman and
she has her own agenda auto cogs in this
movie a lot of things are turning a lot
of things are happening let's talk about
what I liked first first of all I really
like Ben Affleck as Batman / Bruce Wayne
in fact every Batman element in this
movie is my favorite element in the
movie I like Bruce Wayne I liked Alfred
I loved Jeremy Irons as Alfred yet the
quips he had the one-liners I thought
Jeremy Irons was a great pick as Alfred
and when the kick-ass read goes down
with Batman it really goes down he'd
pretty sure he kills folks though I'd
have to watch this movie again and I'll
address it in a spoiler video that I'll
do about it we know all those scenes in
the trailer where he is like a 50 cals
on the batwing and the Batmobile you're
like is he shooting things or people
dying I'm pretty sure that yeah I'm
pretty sure people got shot and killed
and died so if that's gonna piss you off
that's just gonna piss you off in the
movie because I'm pretty sure Batman
kills folks and when the Batman Superman
fight goes down finally at the end of
the movie it's pretty cool to say it's
Batman and Superman fighting on the
screen dude like we have I've waited all
my life for that [ __ ] and this movie
does feel more like a Batman movie then
a Superman movie at first it was kind of
pitched as Man of Steel tube it is not
Man of Steel - and surprisingly the
whole dawn of Justice element I actually
enjoyed - me gal gadot she didn't piss
me off it's Wonder Woman I actually
liked her and in that we finally come to
the things that I didn't really like in
the movie I mean
this is Batman versus Superman anyone
throwing up an early review doesn't want
to be the one to be like hey there [ __ ]
I hated in this movie but hey whatever
I'll take the hit because that's just
that's what I do here props to the movie
in his transparency anything from the
trailer or the casting I felt like it
might suck ass it actually did suck ass
Jesse Eisenberg as Lex Luthor from the
get-go I was like I really don't like
that and I don't see that and he's not
going to be Lex Luthor how Lex Luthor
should probably be and sure enough he's
exactly what he looked like in the
trailer which makes me think he's just a
bad choice because he was kind of like
Jim Carrey playing Lex Luthor that's not
to say he's a spin Tura I'm just saying
there's something about him that made me
go yeah Jim Carrey would be doing the
same exact job here and when Jesse
Eisenberg was delivering certain lines
in this movie I just I I took my brain
and I imagined Michael Rosenbaum
delivering them and I'm like yeah it
just would have been better would have
been redundant and would have been
better and the pacing in this movie this
movie is two and a half hours long did
it need to be I guess to cram everything
in this movie that they were cramming
into this movie yeah it had to be two
and a half hours long however there are
enough elements like threads you can
just see them you're like that didn't
need to be in there they could have
taken that out could have taken that out
shortened down the runtime is just when
it's that easy to see what they could
have done starts to be like hey how
could I see that new not example at the
very beginning of this movie there's a
scenario where people died people look
oh did Superman kill them I don't know
let's kind of put them on trial and
let's see is do we actually need
Superman around that's the question now
but the fact is a do we need a super
human god character on earth is he good
is he bad that's just kind of that is a
conclusion that human beings would reach
on their own you don't need a catalyst
you don't need this event to happen so
right there you could have taken that
event out boom save some time and enough
scenarios that you could take out of the
movie happen in the movie and it starts
to wear on the Pacer and that stupid
thing is as dumb as it looked in the
trailer and the bummer is doomsday in
this movie does exactly what I thought
he would do you know when that trailer
came out and then all of us douchebag
youtubers put up our cameras we were
like it looks like they're just
shoehorning some doomsday CGI
monstrosity into the end of the movie so
they can have Superman Wonder Woman and
Batman fight something exactly what
happens is exactly how it happened so
good job on the transparency trailers I
guess the thing that irritates me about
it is it looks like Batman vs Superman
learn from the Manistee legacy room at
the end of Man of Steel all that
destruction happened where everybody was
like that is way too much destruction
and then Batman vs Superman is happening
it's like yeah I know that's exactly how
Bruce Wayne is going to say it and
that's why he's going to declare war on
this alien who has way too much power
and you're like alright so there was a
method behind the madness there was
almost a reason for all the destruction
so now that that's already happened in
here there's gonna be less destruction
in this movie right no I'm pretty sure
more destruction happens at the end of
this movie because of the whole doomsday
thing and I just feel like they're just
doing it for the sake of because now
like oh okay so that's just a Zack
Snyder thing he just likes blow and shut
up alright guys in the end Batman vs
Superman was one of those movies where
there were things I thought were great
in the movie and things I thought were
[ __ ] in the movie they were apparent
early on because of the trailers and
it's all just kind of come to fruition
to be like oh yeah those paranoia that
you may have had you're justified in him
I love the Bruce Wayne element I love
the Batman element but the pacing
leading up to that conflict just wasn't
there wasn't enough payoff for it two
and a half hours of just watching things
happen alright I still think Jesse
Eisenberg is a miscast as Lex Luthor and
in the end I feel like they just brought
in the whole doomsday thing for the sake
of just explosions and destruction
that's fun admittedly it is fun in that
firework show kind of way I just think a
movie called Batman vs Superman deserved
better
and for that I will say Batman vs
Superman dawn of Justice would have been
a better time if I were drunk yeah now
it's a party wait would Batman versus
Superman I was not the coolest [ __ ]
movie ever the biggest gladiator match
is actually the one that takes place in
here between the part of you the realist
and the optimist the part of you that
wanted to like the movie more than you
actually did and the part of you that
just thought the movie was alright we're
so Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you think comment
below
let me know and as always if you liked
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more